traffic
we're on the line
so I won't tell me down was she ran
right here so it went a little bit over
there and then she went a little bit
there
and since he used to say
I was senses like you know it's very
simple you complicated in other words
you add stuff that shouldn't be there
it's almost like a very precise
technique
it's on the line
I do that I go in it stays on the line
this comes out
and I throw him
so if I move it at all now
I said about contradictions
like this
it stays on the line and then I bring it
and then
so I'm saying
it's a contradiction because I'm saying
don't disturb them but now I'm saying
disturb them but I'm not going both ways
so in my first book I always say don't
go backwards to go forwards so I mean
we don't know we're doing it we can't
see we're doing it but you don't need to
do it
if you want to turn you turn
one way
oh we've got lunch now so after lunch
um
I think this is the best I've actually
ever seen you've worked I know we've
done a few seminars here but you're
certainly working well because there's
not a lot of chats
so that means two things one is your not
only concentrating but you must be
working as well so that's like uh you're
getting it that's the point when we get
it we you know I bet those who use
computers someone will talk to you guys
you're saying to them in a minute even
though you're not going to say in the
words now keep on you go in a minute
yeah have we all been there
but this is a very similar thing in
daily life you know you're engrossed in
what you're doing
oh
calculate oh you threw me out there I've
got a program that I I could almost read
your mind then you went and threw me
with Coke during that game we haven't
really done that have we right so so so
we get programmed as well
even though the book is sign it we get
this program and that's what we have to
then overcome
no not to be programmed or you could say
Intuition or you could say telepathic or
you knew it before they said it so we
have to keep fighting all these things
that make us
impurities so that we become natural
okay enjoy